[Music]
new jobs report out uh where the jobs
are all in one chart
very interesting explosion
in january jobs
in guess what
leisure and hospitality yeah so if you
look at the top three categories first
of all
450 000 jobs nobody predicted that one
right because we were still hearing
things of omicron spreading and so you
know 150 000 new jobs
new jobs were taken yes in the month of
january yeah a big spike and so if we
look at where those are broken down
leisure and hospitality 151 000 of those
so clearly what's happening is we've got
restaurants are uh
reopening in some states across the
country some are staffing back up
due to restrictions coming down i mean
that's just the reality we're seeing in
a lot of states depending on
we're not getting into politics but that
is how this is divided and so as states
are opening up so is the leisure and
hospitality industry and so they're
staffing up obviously professional and
business services that's just a fancy
way of saying
small businesses corporations businesses
are hiring that was the second highest
amount of jobs 86 000 and then this is
interesting the third highest was retail
61 000. so we're seeing
slowly the falling across the country as
it relates to
restrictions and kind of the traditional
economy and so we're seeing retail uh
which has been hit very hard during the
pandemic seeing those jobs being added
it's very interesting and then final
piece transportation and warehousing
this is good for manufacturing uh
specifically dave we've we've seen a big
supply chain problem
uh maybe you've seen it in your grocery
stores depending on where you're
listening and viewing from
but truckers there's a need uh as of
november of 2021
they needed 80 000 truckers to fully
staff up on the supply chain 7 500
truckers were added in the month of
january so it's kind of a snapshot of
not just what's happening but where the
opportunities are for people if let's
just be real you need a bigger shuffle
you know uh you need to add that second
or third job this is where people are
hiring
from an economics standpoint um
in just the movement and the disruption
of labor
the pandemic was
dramatically unfair
to
those who could least afford it
servers
hotel maids
um hourly wager and there's people
working people working retail
none of these are
super high paid gigs
by and large
uh
not none of them but most of them aren't
and uh they were
inordinately the hardest hit
because those were the people that got
completely shut down
and now that medical freedom is coming
back
and people are free
to in some states has been for quite a
while and some it's just now a brand new
thing
to reopen and travel and stay in a hotel
and go to a restaurant now we've got
states that that's still virtually
impossible to do but the
the thing i was hearing at first is is
that they couldn't get them to come back
to work that's true so uh i'm wondering
if this surge
in leisure and hospitality as an example
is the fact that the freaking
unemployment just ran out
yeah well they had to go back to work
yeah well we've got it very magically
they went back to work when there's no
more unemployment that's right uh that's
part of it but we're also seeing that
the pandemic itself spun off a whole
bunch of jobs that didn't exist pre
pandemic so when you're watching the
news folks and you hear this well we've
got this employment gap we've got more
jobs available it's about 10.3 million
versus people are unemployed we're now
getting into low h we're folks we're
steamrolling towards a three percent
dave you're gonna see unemployment rate
in the threes very soon which is by far
below
real employment it's oh yeah we're in a
deficit yeah so what's going on couple
things more jobs have been created that
didn't exist pre-pandemic a lot of
health services job you have a lot of
support staff that are being hired to
support doctors and nurses that's one
example of where
hospitals have staff staffed up now the
other thing that we've seen dave is that
more people are starting businesses in
the pandemic if they were laid off or
furloughed or maybe they stayed with it
but they got some stimulus money and
they wanted to start that side hustle um
as you know and we teach this
entrepreneurship all the time in entre
leadership
the barrier for entry is lower than it
has ever been in the united states to
start a business so we're seeing on the
rolls now more companies have so they're
not going to start a business didn't go
back to the show didn't go back they
also now need to hire people they do
even more jobs so you think about the
person who is making an hourly wage as a
waitress or maybe working in a night
shift at a hotel okay so you're looking
at i'm just ballparking this but this is
somewhere between a 10 to maybe 12 an
hour job
so they can now repent pre-pandemic so
now it's 22 it has jumped however they
went out and said hey i can replace that
and i don't have to work the crazy hours
you know what we could put up with crazy
people at your local chain restaurant
these are the restaurants by the way
that have struggled the most your faster
food services for instance stacy and i
we went to a lovely dinner locally with
my in-laws and my brothers sister all
this weekend we went to a five-star
restaurant let me tell you something
they haven't struggled at all
uh other than the initial shutdown the
servers in there making bank because
it's a great experience and the food's
correct and the services they're the
servers the servers are making great
money because people want to go to a
high-end experience and have great food
if you look at the chain restaurants you
just looked at human behavior that's
where we saw less traffic and things
kind of contract so all that said
we've seen a great entrepreneurship
explosion we're seeing the tip of it
over the next six months i think you're
going to see a record amount of business
starts in fact we already know from the
bureau of labor statistics applications
to start businesses the highest rate
it's ever been there's so the supreme
court mandate comes out and the supreme
court comes side and sets the
biden mandate aside for vaccines
so companies like ours at ramsey
if you want to get a vaccine you can but
we're not going to interfere in your
medical freedom you get to decide we
don't make you do anything
with your medical freedom one way or the
other that's right and uh so companies
like ours are hiring like crazy and
people are leaving these companies that
are clamping down on their med taking
their medical freedoms and coming to
companies like ours so we're still
seeing that great resignation move some
of it is associated with the medical
freedom issue some of it is associated
with just this waking up and i hate my
job and life's too short and the
pandemic reminded me someday i'm gonna
die that's right and one other thing
that we've seen happen companies because
you saw the hourly wage go up with
target walmart amazon leading the way
here's what's happening people are
leaving their jobs record pace 20
million people have left their jobs over
the last five months it's going to
continue why because there's a great
kind of arms race with companies they're
enticing people with signing bonuses and
bigger salaries and that's going to
catch up to people however if you need a
bigger shovel and you're in the ramsey
tribe go get it go get it now yeah it's
going to last forever because it's not
house prices aren't going to be this and
job prices aren't going to be this quite
hot forever supply demand curves always
shift one way or the other they never
stay exactly where they are and that
includes the supply of labor that's
correct this is the ramsey shaft